hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch this
official trailer number two Lady and the
[ __ ] for the Disney Plus streaming
service we are shooting this at 10:00
p.m. at night uploading around 6:00 a.m.
because we just got back from watching
Maleficent mistress of evil keep a
lookout for our deep analysis
scene-by-scene breakdown of that movie
so much to uncover a little doing a
regular overview later this week I'm
excited for Disney for documenting the
car ride back really I'm pretty excited
for Disney Plus mats
everything you love about Disney 1.42
including this movie
[Music]
hi are you - twin summer husband cow
haha
[Music]
[Music]
snob help there we go I can't because
thought they weren't gonna be in at
least the dog moves out
we get this thing off
[Music]
[Music]
it's nostalgia
everything the light touches
every day could be an adventure well
ladies become a real hero it's ladies
movie yeah the ladies movie lady imagery
lady plus a [ __ ] is there yeah we gotta
say you know it's pretty refreshing to
watch this trailer after watching the
Doolittle trailer I feel like the talk
on the on the movie talk circles of
everywhere has been rather you know
negative towards it and we've been like
this fine alright yeah but this it's
refreshing when they're using real pets
there's an arguments you've made in and
of itself there are people I know who
generally don't like the idea of using
any kind of animals and movies for
whatever reasons right this feels like
very believable and real to me and and
what they're doing with just their
mouths slightly moving I find it
refreshing as opposed to just watching
to fully digitally created animal yeah
in a human world like I am I like return
to something older that is a trick that
I feel like has maybe not worked as well
in the past because technology hasn't
quite been utter toward the point where
it can really sell it and I feel like
we've spent so much time going down the
rabbit hole of let's mocap and let's
make hyper photo-real CG and so yeah I
almost imagine that an effect like this
it's a little more classic it's gotta
have gotten a lot better by now I do
appreciate the tangibility of that of
having what appears to be a whole lot of
actual animal performers some CG
assistants there I get the ethical
debate but as long as everything was
handled humanely I guess like I do think
that it is impressive to still like to
create a whole movie with you know
animals as your leads yeah well speaking
of the animals last time we did a
reaction to the first trailer I was like
where are my racist Siamese cats no I
don't think they're gonna make them
Chinese this time around however I
thought they just completely cut out
knowing what helped Disney has been
remaking stuff tonight they're not gonna
do I'm sure I could I'm one Google
search away from finding out don't they
well Jen Janelle Monae is doing the song
I think so she's not Chinese
or you know I wonder if they'll adapt
that to make it a little more
appropriate yeah because we didn't see
any of you know the cats talking but I
did get exactly you know items for cats
a live with us the Siamese cats like no
they did it I'm excited they're back yay
even though they're not the most beloved
element I think because I had sold
myself they're not gonna be in here I'm
excited now it's all of a sudden
expectation exceeded yes well before we
even got the film at all and I love the
production design man I love the world
that they brought like this old-timey
world they really brought to life just
looks like somebody out of the fifties
you know and I think that's exactly what
it even feel like but yeah it does 1778
if I'm not mistaken stellar turn of the
century but III feel like yeah if
there's one thing Disney consistently
nails regardless of how any of these
live-action re-imaginings are going it's
the physical production elements because
the designs are always gorgeous and I do
have to applaud them for putting as much
of that in camera and and you know
hiring costumers and set builders and
people to really make the tangibility of
these big rain remakes work and this is
for streaming but it still looks like
they're investing pretty heavily and it
looks very sweet oh very very sweet very
sweet I've imagined the pretty good
chemistry between lady and [ __ ] there
has to be there's in the last trailer we
barely saw them speaking but you know
add for me I got lost in this trailer
pretty quick watching the the animals
and her eyes you know those movies like
homeward bound it yeah feels it feels
more appropriate to do this approach
here let's figure like remakes it's fun
of me because I fell for it I'm part of
the problem I'm part of the man does he
needs to stop remaking stuff and then
they do a trailer I'm like I can't wait
for this remake this is maybe the tram
has done that to be oh my god I already
doing this is point
and then I watch the trailer like I
can't wait to watch movie yeah
interesting it's an interesting
phenomenon because they don't hate it in
and of itself I think that there is
something innately impressive about the
way they're able to realize these films
in live-action
at the same time yeah it is a little bit
of a kind of like Reese skinning a bunch
of things yeah and there are elements
throughout these remakes and some of
them have hit a lot better than some of
the other ones but I feel like you can
kind of trace the elements that maybe
don't feel quite as natural or ways in
which they're trying to update for the
modern sensibility and I always applaud
the effort they're making and really the
I feel like the consistent criticism we
have is like commit to it don't just
kind of pepper it in here to make us you
know aware of it but distracted but I'm
not really as concerned about that with
this movie there seems something about
this particular reboot that seems kind
of like it's out of its own way and it
just wants to tell the sweet story over
again and it's not too invested in
switching it up yeah you know which you
should do new stuff but at the same time
if they could just nail one of these
retellings without any kind of asterisks
next to it I think that would make
everybody kind of happy well doing a
REIT on a lady in the [ __ ] seems like
something that's much easier to digest
lion king in Jungle Book you know you're
gonna have to digital the hell out of
that or with this we live amongst cats
and dogs and we've seen enough in movies
over the many years many decades that
you can train animals well enough to be
a good performer on camera and the
original movie I remember there was a
different character with the muzzle
mm-hmm I don't think that was lady just
[ __ ] get Muslim so it was like a beaver
or something yep
till I remember that wrong but there was
a beaver and also when the end of the
movie when [ __ ] is in the truck and the
dogs were like tram this trailer may
look like lady's stopping we're seeing
like yeah or as I thought it was like
all the dogs who worked together
man it's been a while I spent a lot of
times I've seen it what I'll do is to be
more negative towards this film I'll
watch the animated one right before I
watch the live action what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna make like a freeze-frame of
every single shot and I'm gonna
hold it up next to the movie / shot and
everything I met deviates I'm gonna mark
a point on its how this works now until
Disney's check alright guys what are you
excited for Lady and the [ __ ] comment
below which one are you a lady or a
[ __ ] do you have a [ __ ] stamp
subscriber the real rejects click that
notification bell and I'd like to end
this with a patient the day shot for a
lady named Jen Smith I don't even busy
with school lately busy life being a
mother in general but I gotta say you
know watching this lady in the [ __ ]
trailer reminded me when you have a
family when you're a mom you gotta make
sure to keep that spark alive with your
hubby I suggest getting a Disney Plus
subscription and binge in some sweet
cute animated films with your hubby over
a nice bucket of popcorn and pasta what
how does that tie into what I'm gonna
yeah you know I just thought starches
Janet just come from French Jen loves
spaghetti eggs I'm just trying to make
the video better i okay sweety has
nothing to do with what I'm talking
about
popcorn mm-hmm some redbull oh yeah no I
get it okay yeah cuz what I don't even
get it
okay this is the point the bit where
were like is either jen-jen I love you
popcorn it'd be happy don't worry
satisfy your husband get some dogs and
watch some movie among them
let them watch you guys in the bedroom